I've got to say markets have gone here
in the US in a complete opposite
direction of what you call for almost a
year ago what gives mark well we have to
clarify this statement I was expecting a
correction for now two years I think
we've gone up in a straight line from
October 2011 up to here with three years
into this bull market where we didn't
have more than a ten percent correction
and this year has been irregular so some
indices like the S&P our upper modest
six percent and the russell 2000 is down
four percent fifty percent of shares on
nasdaq are down twenty percent for more
from their recent eyes in asia we had
markets like the Philippines Indonesia
Vietnam India Thailand Pakistan that are
all updating twenty percent and
twenty-eight percent right so when
people tell me that the S&P has been
such a great place to be I have to laugh
because emerging markets in Asia at
least have done fantastically well I
relatives relatively speaking yes I they
haven't performed as well as some of
those other markets you're talking about
by the way yes and by the way last fall
I was interviewed and I said I thought
that at the time Treasury notes yielding
three percent would be an interesting
investment and their yield has fallen to
below 2.5% and the doll has been strong
so I don't know what you're complaining
about what do you mean you don't know
what I'm complaining about hang on hang
on one second mark really you make it
sound as if i'm wrong about everything i
projected